dès septembre vous assisterez à des
concerts des matchs et des salons dans
cette salle le jeu de paume
c'est le nouvel espace de
l'agglomération blésoise qui mêle
culture sport et économie une salle
recouverte de bois et de zinc totalement
modulable une sorte de 3 en 1 la jauge
peut passer de 2500 personnes les soirs
de match de basket à 3150 pour les
concerts grâce à un système de fauteuils
modulable si vous avez besoin d'un parc
et tant mieux il est là vous avez besoin
d'un sol souple pvc pour le handball
vous choisissez vous avez besoin de la
dalle béton pour le concert vous
choisissez votre set auparavant les
manifestations se faisait dans la halle
aux grains dans le centre ville ou sous
de grands barnums ne pouvant accueillir
qu'un millier de personnes agglopolys la
communauté d'agglomération a choisi
cette salle multi modale d'une grande
capacité pour se positionner sur des
événements d'envergure l'investissement
25 millions d'euros
nous sommes donc à une demi-heure de nos
deux métropoles régionales tours et
orléans est effectivement pour un public
parisien
nous sommes à une heure et demie mais
surtout après cinq minutes une fois
qu'on est sortie d'autoroute donc nous
avons énormément d'atouts je crois que
cette salle du jeu de paume
elle va peser elle va compter les
premiers à fouler le parquet les
basketteurs de la dea blois fini les
matches dans les gymnases saint georges
le jeu de paume devient le qg de
l'équipe les gradins pourront accueillir
2500 spectateurs au lieu des 1000 100
sièges du gymnase autres installations
une salle de musculation et des
vestiaires et un terrain dédié à
l'équipe
les partenaires du club ne seront pas en
reste ils seront accueillis ici dans
cette salle de 400 personnes et je pas
peur de dire qu'aujourd'hui je pense
qu'on aura une des plus belles salles de
pro b c'est vrai que pour nous c'est aux
siennes en éléments facilitant pour
attirer des joueurs qui peut être
jusqu'à maintenant
baptisé euro et venir a beau jouer dans
mon âge il a
c'est pas toc toc le jeu de paume sera
inauguré le premier week-end de
septembre avec un match amical de la dea
bois face à poitiers suivi d'un concert
gratuit de véronique sanson